AdWords allows you to create ads that
are designed especially for mobile users
with the prevalence of mobile users
across the world optimizing for ads on
mobile is a great way to acquire new
customers there are a ton of options on
AdWords to appeal to your customers on
mobile including text ads image ads at
promotions call-only ads not to mention
all the other ad options you have within
actual apps on different phones and
tablets think about your audience when
determining what type of AD you want to
use think about where they are when
they're viewing your ad for example
people seeing your ads on mobile or more
likely to want to know where you are and
how to call you so you can consider
using a text ad to show your location
and your phone number with location
extensions and call extensions or you
can use a call only ad which will
include a call button in your ad now
think about it when you're looking for
Starbucks and you search the term on
your mobile phone how easy is it to
click on the location extension and go
directly to your nearest Starbucks also
consider creating ads devoted to people
on mobile devices for example using the
mobile version of your website as your
landing page and your regular text ads
may appear differently on mobile so keep
that in mind when you're designing them
check out the instructor notes for more
information on that one perk of image
ads is you don't actually need to change
anything on mobile except the link to
your mobile site these ads are the same
ads that are going to show up on your
desktop you just want to make sure
you're linking to the right landing page
however you're going to need to opt in
to the Display Network in your settings
or search network with display selected
we'll talk more about display networks
later app promotion ads or also known as
click to download ads are one of the
best ways to get your app downloaded
easily and efficiently for customers
these are designed to show up on devices
that will have the most impact so you're
not going to see these popping up on
your desktop determining the right
options for you is all about knowing
your audience and what devices they're
going to be using so you can design your
ads appropriately